let's say we have the radical equation 2
x
minus 1
is equal to the square root of 8 minus x
so we already have the radical isolated
on one side of the equation so we might
say well let's just get rid of the
radical let's square both sides of this
equation so we might say that this is
the same thing as 2x minus 1 squared is
equal to the square root of 8
minus x
8 minus x squared and then we would get
let's see 2x minus 1 squared is 4x
squared minus 4x plus 1 is equal to
8 minus x now we have to be we have to
be very very very careful here you we
might feel okay we did legitimate
operations we did the same thing to both
sides that these are equivalent
equations but they aren't quite
equivalent because when you're squaring
something one way to think about it is
when you're squaring it you're losing
information so for example this would be
true even if the original equation were
2x i mean it's in a different color
even if the original equation where 2x
minus 1 is equal to the negative
of the square root of 8 minus x
because if you squared both sides of
this you would also get
you would also get that right over there
because the negative squared would be
equal to a positive so when we're
finding a solution to this we need to
test our solution to make sure it's
truly the solution to this first yellow
equation here and not the solution to
this up here if it's a solution to this
right hand side or not the yellow one
then we would call that an extraneous
solution so let's see if we can solve
this
so let's let's write this as kind of a
standard quadratic let's let's subtract
8 from both sides
so let's
subtract 8 from both sides to get rid of
this 8 over here and let's add x to both
sides
so plus x
plus x
and we are going to get
we are going to get 4 x squared
minus 3x
minus 7
minus 7 is equal to
is equal to
zero
and let's see we would want to factor
this right over here and let's see maybe
i could do this by
if i do it by well i'll just use the
quadratic formula here so the solutions
are going to be
x
is going to be equal to negative b so 3
plus or minus the square root of b
squared so negative 3 squared is 9
minus 4
times a which is 4
times c which is negative seven so i
could just say times i'll just write
i'll write a seven here then that
negative is going to make this a
positive
all of that over two a so two times four
is eight so it's going to be three plus
or minus the square root of
let's see 4 times 4
is 16
times 7 16 times
is going to be 70 plus 42 let me make
sure i'm doing this right
so 16 times 7 2
so it's 112
plus 9. so 121 that worked out nicely
so plus or minus the square root of 121
all of that over 8 well that is equal to
3 plus or minus 11 all of that over
all of that over 8. so that is equal to
if we add 11 that is 14 8
or if we subtract 11 3 minus 11
is negative 8
negative 8 divided by 8 is negative 1.
so we have to think about you might say
okay i found two solutions to the
radical equation but remember one of
these might be solutions to this
alternate radical equation that got lost
when we squared both sides we have to
make sure that they're legitimate or
maybe one of these is an extraneous
solution in fact one is very likely the
solution to this radical equation which
wasn't our original goal
so let's see
let's try out x equals negative 1.
if x equals negative 1 we would have 2
times negative 1 minus 1 is equal to the
square root of 8 minus negative 1. so
that would be negative 2
minus one is equal to the square root of
is equal to square root of nine and so
we'd have negative three is equal to the
square root of nine the principal number
right this is the positive square root
this is not true so this right over here
that is an extraneous solution
extraneous
solution
it is a solution to this one right over
here because notice for that one
you if you substitute 2 times negative 1
minus 1 is equal to the negative of
8 minus negative 1. so this is negative
3 is equal to the negative of
3. so it checks out for this one so this
one right over here is the extraneous
solution this one right over here is
going to be the actual solution for our
original equation and you can test it
out on your own in fact i encourage you
to do so